und daran waren bei uns ja schon so
vieles in seinem leben gemacht hat der
leon löwen trat genauso begeistert wie
katrin göring eckardt schauen wir wie
sie ihn anhimmelt ja und er vielleicht
der schauspieler ist der für seine
arbeit so viele bohnen gegessen hat wie
kein anderer
wer ist dieser mann den alle kennen der
aber von sich sagt ich wollte am anfang
um keinen preis schauspieler werden das
war die hölle
ich hatte lampenfieber wann ist der
knoten geplatzt stimmt es dass er einen
gewissen carlo pedersoli als junge im
schwimmbad kennenlernte der als
italienische olympia schwimmer am
beckenrand stand und eine nach der
anderen rauchte und später als bud
spencer mit ihm weltberühmt wurde
was war das für eine freundschaft wie
wichtig war das essen stimmt es dass bud
spencer in der lage war gesamte
speisekarte rauf und runter zu essen
wie wichtig ist der deutsche teil seiner
geschichte für ihn
und warum war sein neuer film auch eine
rückkehr zu den anfängen herzlich
willkommen terrorzellen freuen
[Applaus]
die weniger
weniger bei denen man das so erlebt was
bedeutet ihnen interessiert die haben
wirklich in der ddr heimlich als bücher
filme geguckt
also natürlich liefen da rauf und runter
die liga in west fernsehen liefen die
rauf und runter und ich lebte nicht in
sachsen also im tal der ahnungslosen wo
man das nicht gucken konnte sondern dem
schönen thüringer und deswegen ist sind
die filmen fester bestandteil meiner
kindheit und haben sich damals in dieses
in diese blauen augen verliebt ja ein
bisschen 'schon geblieben ja wir müssen
jetzt hier ist aber wirklich endlich
hätte ich nie gedacht dass schon ganze
cd r bürgerinnen eingeschlossen in der
hinter der mauer und und jetzt neben
tänzen im leben jetzt kann ich meine
mehr blau geht nicht seine blauen ab
heute dem blau ist ein anzug angezogen
den nicht finden konnte aber gut dass
wir der schwimmer terence hill in
italien immer noch ein riesen stein als
sie leben ja tritt auf als andere
materie als priester der gebrochene
herzen heilt und in einem kleinen ort in
ungarn ingo bio für das rechte sorgt ich
finde ja dass priester in filmen pater
brown oder eben auch bei materie immer
sehr viel sympathischer sind als in echt
und deswegen ist ja glaube ich
inzwischen italien fast bekannter als
der papst habe ich das ja möglicherweise
arbeitet bis heute wie waren sich von
lehrern löwentraut weiß ich dass er bei
seiner oma frühjahr bud spencer film
geguckt hat und jetzt kommt die große
überraschung terence hill spricht
deutsch ja etwas schon meine mutter war
es aus dresden
so ich habe deutsch gesprächen
gesprochen bis sechs jahre erst morgen
dann sind wir nach italien dann bloß
italienisch und dazu diese nachher mega
bloß englisch und jetzt spreche keine
presse keine sprache richtig sich hier
also wir finden das toll
[Musik]
ihre frau mit der sie seit wie vielen
jahren verheiratet sind 50 jahre
wahnsinn des lebens sprechen sie zu
hause dann wenn sie in amerika leben
seit 30 jahren machen sie so geboren
aber ihre eltern kamen von bayern und
das sind auch verwandelt
ich besuche sie zwar manchmal ja und ich
mache sie die machen mir ein schönes
frühstück mit viele brötchen
also habe ich das ist ja ganz gern ist
so die warum ich jetzt ja sie haben auch
so leicht bayerischen akzent finde ich
so ein bisschen ja nicht nicht direkt
sagen also nicht so und mach das nochmal
fünf für mich auch zu klären
mario girotti ist der ist es ihr
geburtsname aber steht das steht ihm
passt es damals
wenn man die italiener gestern gemacht
haben
sie sind in der ganzen welt gegangen und
die leute haben gedacht dass der
amerikanische chemie war ja schon jeder
musste ein neues namen nicht bloß die
schauspieler aber die ganze crew
die haben ja wort ein so ein silbern und
haben wir verschiedene namen geben
du hast 24 stunden zu denn dann haben
wir haben gesagt hast es gibt doch einen
terenzi ohnmacht ein genau und dann hier
spricht sich der jänner keine st
so ist es zu dem namen gekommen ja ja ja
und so ist auch bud spencer auch zu
sagen ja an compass besser er hat ganz
allein sorge geliebt genau schauspieler
und beliebt wir so dass des wortspiels
gehen das hat er hier mal das muss dem
band hat mit dem bier zu tun das war der
grund dass fast hat gesagt sie wären
sozusagen an den ort zurück wo alles
begonnen hat in der wüste von almeria ja
dort ging das los geht s los mal wo ich
bud spencer getroffen habe die
geschichte ist dass die hat die sich zu
firmen heißt jetzt laut volker django
nie
die originale titel war die katze hund
und die fuchs okay dann verstehen wir
auch diese charaktere wenn du weißt dass
ich die katze gespielt hat eine sehr
hohe theaterversion und ich bin ja immer
schlauer
das sind auch auf den zum so gegeben da
hatte du bist ja gesagt du musst schauen
wie eine tiger hatte mich sagen sowas
ist das aber ist das ensemble gerne aber
das interessiert ihn zugegangen und
haben die gesichtsausdrücke von tigern
studiert spielt ja ich habe sie wirklich
wollen
das sagte ein tiger und eine katze guckt
es aber nicht und gerade aber geht durch
die hindurch ja zu sagen
genau das ist gelöst und können sie
einmal schauen wie ein tiger aber dass
die es war wirklich ein moment wo war
denn die haben uns schon von einer woche
gedreht aber dann hat der schauspieler
die alte karte gespielt hat hat sich
verletzt weil sie seine die geschichte
stimmt ja also ich eben ja ich habe das
gelesen ist wurde schon eine woche
gedreht und dann hat er sich verletzt
das bein gebrochen weil er sich
angeblich so mit seiner freundin
gestritten ja genau was war das für eine
freundin
dann haben ist ja gemacht und darum kann
ich bin haben in gruppe d ist gut und
dann schnell musste mir zurück dann habe
ich im flugzeug nach madrid aber damals
gibt da kein flughafen in andrea keine
autobahn haben wir nicht nachts gefahren
für zwei stunden weil sich sogar so und
dann ich habe mir gerade gleich ab ins
bett gebracht und der taxi tages sei
warte hier und ich schlucke das erste
ungefähr da war die kuh und plötzlich
kommt zwei frau zu mir und ich sage darf
ich darauf stehen hier im moment ja ich
glaub ich jetzt sagen sie haben auch
gerne klagt ja dann die frau hat ein
handtuch so und du den hahn zu mit
meinem freund von mir und sagte sie
sieht einen großen haus und dann ist ja
die hosen ausgezogen sie stehen mit in
der wüste zuvor habe ich so gemacht aber
das war eine wüste war niemand
[Applaus]
wir können dieses thema ruhig komplett
nach spieler sondern jetzt günstig bis
zu alle tanzen dann kommen dann bin ich
auch gelaufen und dann wieso man war da
und das halt so ist besser und sonntag
gesagt die es spielen soll ist an einer
schlägerei überraschend so dass ich
sagen will was willst du eine schlägerei
wir haben gesagt haben die wird der hund
muss bloß ein und sonja ricard ist ok
weil die szene endet so die szene endet
dann das fenster den lehrplan hat wir
haben vielleicht eine stunde gesprochen
so macht man nicht als werbung gesehen
später hat er das gesagt vielleicht gebe
ich ihnen so ok und das ist nicht nur
dann haben wir ja wahnsinn
ich meine ich habe bud spencer zweimal
hier lediglich ich finde zu einer der
nettesten menschen den ich will doch
nicht jeder gegen greven jetzt auch so
liebevoll über sie gesprochen sagte may
es wird immer berichtet wir mögen uns
eigentlich gar nicht das stimmt nicht
sondern wir sind wirklich lebensfreunde
geworden das war ein unglaublich
herzlicher mensch und wenn man ihn
erlebt hat und heute auch sie erlebt
versteht man dass weder er noch sie auch
nur einer fliege etwas zuleide tun
können das war ja vielleicht folgt ja in
dem film so schnell es geht wieder eine
szene wo die die die junge frau sagt ich
würde ich habe gespielt mit 1 und 11
meinem damals hat sich einzige schlacht
ungeschlagen so auch die andy anson
leben ja genau 22 pazifisten die berühmt
geworden sind einfach durch unglaubliche
schlägereien und diese freundschaft hat
gehalten bis zum schluss ich habe bis
zum schluss immer davis eifersüchtig wir
gute freunde
wir haben beide sehr
sind meine ja einfache leute einfache
leute und er hat immer gesagt wenn wir
uns getroffen aber wir sind wieder
zurück in die schule jedes mal ein neuer
film gemacht ist wie es war
auch wenn das wahr wir haben spaß gehabt
wie wir haben sie terence von seinem tod
erfahren wann und wo also das ist so ein
event von heimisch ist weil es hat auch
zu tun mit meinen film
wir haben gesucht ein platz wo ich
wollte dass man sich renner wie mit
hitchcock weißt du diesen haus darin
sieht man es so mal so und so ähnlich
haben die seenotretter sagt für mich das
ist ein guter platz aber ich wollte
immer mehr sehen und ich war nach gehen
wir noch mehr sehen wird
die wüste war es dann plötzlich hat mein
handy und dann lang sind dann ist
giuseppe person von der song hat dieser
mann war das werk gegangen
in diesem moment wirklich wirklich
traurig aber nach nicht lange ich konnte
ein feuerwerk an das meint hess gekommen
das ist ja bloß so es war der beginn um
die ennser freund carlo hat also bud
spencer hat hier erzählt dass ihr euch
gelegentlich zum pasta essen verabredet
hat in rom
und er sagte immer terence war immer
total froh wenn ich ihn eingeladen habe
weil seine frau hat ihm keine nudeln
gegeben damit er nicht dick wird
[Gelächter]
funktioniert das ist
[Applaus]
die
das ist genau die abo sieht ja wir haben
immer zusammen gegessen weil taylor hat
sich frau die das macht sie aber nicht
die härte hat sie brauchen um 11 uhr hat
sich sehr einig dass das will ich ja da
haben immerhin zusammen gegessen und
aber dann haben wir auch damals was
immer eigentliche fehler da haben wir
zusammen geschlafen aber den wohnwagen
und dann aber dann hat er mal gesagt ich
sage das nicht du isst mehr ich und ich
würde es wissen
terence eine zum schluss eine sache
würde ich sie noch gerne fragen ich habe
irgendwo gelesen
sie sind ja auch ein zeitzeuge der
dresdner bombennacht sie sind 1939
geboren und dann in den wirren des
krieges in die nähe von dresden ein
kleiner ort der haut gezogen und haben
dort sozusagen aus der ferne die
bombardierung von dresden erlebt ja es
war ich wirklich keine nach gefährlichen
kurve und was himmel ganz rot und dann
einige sagt der vater von diesen kennt
ist da hat er mein vater war ein kämpfer
und hat eine chemische fabrik gearbeitet
in dresden und er will es kurz machen
war auch etwas wie ich vielleicht aber
ich bin wie meine mutter und dann hat er
für eine woche ist nicht gekommen dann
meine mutter bruder gesagt jetzt hole
ich unterhalte ist mit einem fahrrad
gegangen bei dieser blick und dann hat
sich ungesund hat gehört und dann was
mein vater war aber auf dem baum da was
da an hat sich rasieren und noch nicht
gesagt dass wir was wollen
ich sagte mir gesagt dass ich hier
bleiben soll die fabrik zu bewältigen
und jajaja uns aber verträgt was also
dass ihr vater war da mittendrin und hat
die das entferner überlegt ja wie immer
die fabriken sind habe
wie ich kaputt aber nicht noch weiter
privat sind
und stimmt es dass sie noch jahrelang
davon geträumt haben ich habe geträumt
für bis 25 jahre
von dieser geschichte ja und so ich habe
meine gedanken was ist wenn ich hier
heute da ist man bomben wie wir das
wasser schmeiße und denke nicht an die
kennt das sind wir die ganze zu leben
verlässt
so mahne ich habe ich frage immer die
reiter vom dom at und bitte bitte schaut
etwas gegen des sailing aufkaufen und
nun kaufen was ein grab jahre müssen was
es gibt
das heißt
si
gerade ein bisschen schnell fasst das
noch mal kurz zusammen sie würden
sozusagen auf die autoren von don matteo
der para servierten sie ein und sagen
schreib solche szenen dann mach ich ja
nicht mal den leuten klar machen nicht
wissen filme aber wenn ich nochmals sein
team usa ist wenn du das nicht mache ich
mache es nicht mehr das sagen sie sagen
ja weil dieses bekam bekommen wie ein
spiel es ist ja furchtbar ich meine ich
merke jetzt im süden sind 79 jahre alt
und bis heute geht ihnen das neue spiel
noch böse kann ich verstehen nicht hat
dann aber heute
grüße
dass man mit einem wort
dann läutete und dann vor sich hat
vorgestern gesessen ich habe geschrieben
für material ein moment wo er sagt das
eine hat was ist von meinem vater gesagt
hat seine mädchen aus dem haus gebrannt
und in ein paar sekunden ein skelett um
ja durch die hitze naja der hitze aber
der haben das mir geschrieben haben sie
ausgestellt das geschieht ja es war zu
viel wie schwachsinn mir dass wir das
nicht nehmen kann
man muss bloß lachen und glos
entertainen aber kann es nicht war ein
das war